VISAS FOR THESE TYPE OF
WORKERS AND FEEL COMFORT BE
IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, CATHY.
I APPRECIATE IT.
STEVE CORTES WORKED ON
DONALD TRUMP'S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN ON HISPANIC
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND HE
TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT SORT OF
PRESS A LITTLE BIT ON THE
ECONOMIC RATIONALE FOR THIS.
AND NO ONE IS ATTACKING THE
IMMIGRANTS.
I'M CERTAINLY NOT.
HAVE YOU GOT TO WONDER ABOUT
THE MOTIVE IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE ARGUING
SIMULTANEOUSLY THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS MAKING LOW
WAGE JOBS DISAPPEAR AND
THAT'S TRUE, AND AT THE SAME
WORKERS IN THIS COUNTRY?
WHAT IS THE ACTUAL MOTIVE
YOU CAN'T HAVE BOTH WAYS,
TUCKER.
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
BY THE WAY I SAY THIS AS AN
HISPANIC AND IMMIGRANTS SON.
NO ONE SUFFERS MORE FROM
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION THAN
HISPANIC AMERICANS.
AND LEGAL IMMIGRANTS GO
THROUGH A DIFFICULT, LONG
PROCESS TO BECOME AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
SO, THEY ARE THE MOST
CHEATED WHEN WE ALLOW AND
TOLERATE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
BUT WHAT'S THE MOTIVE HERE?
WHY DOES THE LEFT WANT SO
MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
WHY DO THEY WANT AMNESTY?
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT IT
TUCKER.
THEY WANTS THEIR VOTES.
THE MORE AMNESTY THEY GRANT
THE MORE VOTES THEY WILL
GET.
THEY HAVE BEEN SYSTEMIC
DECLINE STATE HOUSES IN
REVERSE IS THAT IS MILLIONS
OF NEW WORKERS.
MILLIONS WHO WILL FLOOD THE
WORKFORCE.
AND AS YOU SAID CREATE AN
UNNATURALLY LOW WAGE TO
COMPETE WITH AMERICAN
WORKERS, MANY OF THEM
HISPANIC.
SO, IT IS A CRASS POLITICAL
CALCULUS WHICH THEY HAVE
ENGAGED IN AND WHICH THEY
ARE PURSUING.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE IT'S AN
INVERSION OF THE DUTY OF
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS TO LOOK
OUT FOR ITS OWN PEOPLE.
IT'S OWN CITIZENS.
HERE YOU HAVE A STATE,
CALIFORNIA, WHERE THE MIDDLE
CLASS -- ENRICHING ALL OUT
NEIGHBORING STATES U AND
BEING REPLACED BY POOR
PEOPLE WITH NO SKILLS WHO
AREN'T EVEN HERE LEGALLY.
THAT SEEMS LIKE THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE DOING TO ITS OWN
PEOPLE.
>> WELL, TUCKER, OF COURSE
IT IS.
WHICH IS WHY BY THE WAY,
FAR FROM IT.
IT'S WHY WE NEED TO MOVE TO
MERIT BASED IMMIGRATION.
CHAIN MIGRATION HAS BEEN A
ECONOMIC SECURITY.
NATIONAL SECURITY.
VISA LOTTERY SYSTEM IS AN
INSANITY THAT HAS TO BE
ENDED YESTERDAY.
WE NEED TO MOVE TO AN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR AMERICA.
PEOPLE WHO BRING DRIVE AND
SKILLS AND WHO LOVE OUR
COUNTRY AND LOVE OUR VALUES.
THAT'S WHERE WE WERE
HISTORICALLY AND WHERE WE
NEED TO BE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT CHAIN
MIGRATION, CALIFORNIA WOULD
BE THE CALIFORNIA THAT VOTED
FOR RONALD REAGAN TWICE.
IT'S HAD MASSIVE POLITICAL
UPSIDE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
YOU LUS THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS ENGAGED IN.
RIGHT.
CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S
FASHION OR TELEVISION OR
POLITICS, WHAT HAPPENS THERE
DOES PLEAD INTO THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY.
AND WE SHOULD TAKE NOTICE.
DO WE WANT TO BECOME
CALIFORNIA WHICH RIGHT NOW
IS IN MANY WAYS A THIRD
RICH ELITES AND INCREDIBLY
IMPOVERISHED DEPENDENT
UNDERCLASS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WANTS TO CREATE
THROUGH ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
THAT'S NOT THE AMERICA THAT
AMERICANS WANT TO LIVE IN.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY RIGHT.